Türme,
ein Toilettenhäuschen
und ein Schlosstor.
Das alles hat Günther Beinert gebaut.
Es ist das Schloss Mansfeld
im deutschen Bundesland Sachsen-Anhalt
– im Maßstab 1:25.
Eineinhalb Jahre betrug die Bauzeit.
Ich habe was geschaffen,
wo ich selber nicht dran gedacht hab‘.
So ist es.
Mehr als 80 Modelle von in Deutschland
real existierenden Burgen und Schlössern
hat der mittlerweile 87-jährige
Hobbybastler gebaut.
Allein in seiner Heimatstadt Gerbstedt in
Sachsen-Anhalt stehen mehr als 40.
Sein größtes Werk ist das Schloss Mansfeld.
Es hat einen Umfang von
38 Metern und ist sogar begehbar.
Das Bauwerk thront auf einer
Fläche von 120 Quadratmetern.
Das echte Schloss steht auf der
Burg Mansfeld im Südharz.
Im 11. Jahrhundert erbaut, war sie einst die
größte Festung in Mitteldeutschland.
Das Schloss Wettin ist auch
eine Arbeit von Günther Beinert.
Sein Baumaterial:
Zement und Bauschutt.
Das sind alte ‚Biberschwänze',
also Dachziegel,
die habe ich kleingeschlagen
und [denn] wieder zusammengefügt,
aber jeder Eckstein musste
mit der Zange bearbeitet werden.
Keine Technik,
alles per Hand.
So formte er tausende Miniziegelsteine.
Günther Beinert hat einst Maurer gelernt.
Als Modellvorlage nimmt
er lediglich kleine Sammelbilder.
Die gab es in den 1930er- und 40er-Jahren
beim Kauf von Zigaretten dazu.
Die erste Burg habe ich
im Elternhaus gebaut
als Fantasieburg,
und weil ich mich denn dran gefreut hab‘…
Ich weiß auch nicht,
warum [dass] sich das so entwickelt hat.
1949 hat Günther Beinert mit dem
Burgenbauen begonnen
und konnte nicht mehr aufhören.
Irgendwann wurden es so viele,
dass im eigenen Garten kein Platz mehr war.
Da half die Stadt und bot ihm
Flächen zum Aufstellen an.
Geld hat er für keine
seiner Burgen bekommen.
Ich mache es ja für die Bevölkerung
und für die Kinder vor allen Dingen,
und die sollen sich freuen,
und das Ergebnis ist mein Lohn.
Mehr will ich ja gar nicht.
Günther Beinert ist ein Phänomen.
Denn er hat nicht nur Burgen,
sondern auch Lokomotiven gebaut
und dabei an jedes noch
so kleine Detail gedacht.
Die Modelle stehen auf dem ehemaligen
Gerbstedter Bahnhofsgelände.
Darunter eine der weltweit größten
Lokomotiven, genannt „Big Boy“.
Und Deutschlands erste Dampflok: der
„Adler“ aus dem Jahr 1835.
Das Kuriose ist, ich war ja nie Eisenbahner
und Ahnung von Lokomotiven
hatte ich gar nicht.
Ich hatte aber einen Kollegen
von Sangerhausen,
der hat mich mit Bildmaterial versorgt,
und da hat mich eine Lokomotive
mehr gereizt wie die andere.
Und so sind eben über 40 – 42 Lokomotiven
sind hier entstanden.
Die Modelle sind zu einer Attraktion
in Gerbstedt geworden.
Ein Burgenwanderweg verbindet alle
Miniatur-Schlösser miteinander.
Auf sein Gesamtwerk ist
Günther Beinert stolz.
Ich stehe davor, jetzt zum Beispiel,
und frage mich:
Wie hast du’s bloß gemacht?
Wie hast du’s gemacht?
Burgen, Schlösser und Lokomotiven
aus Bauschutt und Beton
- dieses Freilichtmuseum
ist wohl einzigartig in der Welt.